did you know that you're required to
have a magnetic compass anytime you fly
an airplane because of that there's a
really good chance that you could see
questions about it on your check ride
and your written exam so let's look at
the things you need to know so you can
really sock it to the faa with the
knowledge that you got from the best
free pilot training available
the mag compass has been used in
navigation for hundreds of years
and as a pilot you're also going to be
expected to know how to use it for two
reasons
first if your airplane has an older
heading indicator like mine does you'll
have to update that every 15 minutes or
so in flight by using the magnetic
compass the other reason is that even if
you have one of those fancy new digital
hsi's that thing could go out on you and
if it does and you're not familiar with
that area you'll need some way to
navigate your way back home but oddly
enough there's actually quite a few
things you need to know about the old
whiskey compass before you can use it
with any kind of accuracy before we talk
about that let's talk about the basic
principles of how this thing works so as
you know at the very top of the earth we
have the north pole and anyone who's
anyone knows that santa claus lives
somewhere in this location and if you
weren't already aware this is also
called true north and magnetic compasses
don't actually point to true north
instead they actually point to a spot in
northern canada and we call this
magnetic north in the simplest terms the
core of the earth is basically a giant
magnet and just like a smaller magnet
magnetic lines of force extend out of
the poles and surround the globe kind of
like what you see here
then what happens is the north and south
poles of the magnets in your compass
want to align themselves with these
magnetic lines of force
because of that we can take a magnet and
set it on top of the compass card to
give us a good indication of where
magnetic north is the compass card is
then placed on a thin axis so it can
spin freely but this comes with some
complications
directly over the equator the lines of
force are basically parallel with the
earth's surface
but as you get closer to the poles these
lines kind of dip towards the earth's
core and the magnet on top of your
compass still wants to align itself with
these lines of force so it actually
pulls down on the compass card in these
areas and the closer you get to the
poles the worse this gets and we call
this magnetic dip
so there are two basic problems that are
caused by magnetic dip acceleration
errors and turning errors
now it's really important to remember
that the direction of these errors
really depends on which hemisphere
you're in so we're going to focus on the
northern hemisphere today because that's
where i'm at sorry guys but in the
southern hemisphere everything's
basically going to be reversed but
remember as you get closer to the
equator these errors basically go away
and that's because those lines of force
are parallel with the earth's surface
now as i mentioned before the compass
card is balanced on this really thin
axis now it might seem unnoticeable to
you in the plane but one side of your
compass card is actually pulled down a
little bit by dip when this happens it
causes a little bit of a shift in the
center of gravity which means there's
more weight on this other side now and
so now what this causes is an inertia
problem remember that guy sir isaac
newton you know objects at rest tend to
stay at rest and objects in motion tend
to stay in motion well that's exactly
what's happening now that weight on one
side is harder to get going but it's
also harder to stop once it gets going
okay so now that you get that let's look
at acceleration errors when we
accelerate that means the airplane is
speeding up now these errors only occur
on east and westbound headings and so
when we speed up that heavier side is
getting pulled back by inertia and this
makes the compass card turn just a
little bit and in the northern
hemisphere it'll always indicate a turn
to the north even though you're not
actually turning
then once your speed stabilizes the
compass card will go back to the correct
heading now if you decelerate or slow
down that weight is pushed forward
because the heavier weight wants to keep
going as the airplane slows and this
will cause your compass card to turn and
indicate a turn to the south but
remember the compass card is not
affected on north or southbound headings
and that's because that weight is
directly in line with the direction of
travel
and just like i said before at the
equator there's no dip so you don't have
to worry about this if you fly there
alright so now the acronym that everyone
uses to remember all this is the word
ands accelerate north decelerate south
if i speed up the compass is going to
indicate a turn to the north and if i
slow down the compass will indicate a
turn to the south and remember it'll be
the opposite in the southern hemisphere
next we have turning errors and these
are really only a problem when you're
turning to the north or turning to the
south alright so let's say we're on a
northbound heading now so i've got some
dip pulling down the compass card in the
front there that means i've got more
weight back here with me now if i make a
left-hand turn that weight just wants to
stay right where it's at and initially
the compass card turns in the opposite
direction
then it kind of lags behind all the way
through the turn
if you're a little bit confused right
now that's probably because the compass
card actually turns backwards and that's
because we're sitting on the outside of
the compass rose so in this situation
since our indicated heading lags behind
that means the compass will undershoot
turns to the north so what's that mean
to me that means i need to go past the
heading i want to fly okay well how much
do i need to go past it i doubt very
seriously you get asked this on your
check ride but for all you aviation
nerds out there the pilot's handbook of
aeronautical knowledge says 15 degrees
plus half the latitude that means if i'm
at 40 degrees north i need to take 15
degrees and half of 40 is 20 so 35
degrees so i need to roll out 35 degrees
past the heading i want to fly all right
so let's say we're making turns near
southbound heading that would mean the
magnetic dip would be back here with me
and there'd be more weight in the front
up there from here if i make a left turn
that weight in the front wants to stay
right where it's at so that's going to
make the heading jump ahead of where it
actually is
and once again i know this is really
confusing because these stupid compass
has turned backwards
so the compass will overshoot turns to
the south so what's that mean to me i
need to end the turn early well how much
the pilot's handbook of aeronautical
knowledge says we can use the same
formula 15 degrees plus half the
latitude so in this case if i'm at 30
degrees north i'll take 15 and half of
30 is 15 so 15 plus 15 is 30 degrees so
that means i need to roll out 30 degrees
before the heading i want to fly now
once again if we're on an east or
westbound heading that way is directly
in line with the direction we want to
travel so on east or westbound headings
we don't have any turning errors if
you'd like to remember these turning
ears one way to do that is to remember
the acronym unos undershoot north
overshoots south and remember it'll be
the opposite in the southern hemisphere
so why do i care about these dip errors
as a pilot
not only do you have to be aware of it
in order to use the compass for backup
navigation but you also need to make
sure that you're in straight level and
unaccelerated flight when you update
your heading indicator if you want to be
accurate anyways
next we have variation and that's
basically the difference in magnetic
north and true north for example if
you're sitting here on the globe and
your compass is pointing over here to
magnetic north and true north is up here
this angle right here would be your
variation and if i'm lucky enough to be
on a spot on the globe where magnetic
north is lined up with true north then
my variation would be zero in this case
now that you've got that down let's go
into a little bit more detail let's say
true north is up here and magnetic north
is over here to the west let's say it's
8 degrees to the west from my position
to be exact now let's say i want to go
directly north on a 360 heading and i'm
talking about true north so 360 would be
my true heading
now all i have to do is add eight
degrees to get a corrected heading of
zero zero eight
and this is the magnetic heading i would
fly in order to get a true heading of
three six zero and that's because if i
flew a three six zero using my compass i
would actually be flying a true heading
of 352 degrees
okay let's say from where i am magnetic
north is east of true north six degrees
to be exact if i want to fly 360 heading
in this case i would have to subtract 6
degrees and that would give me a
corrected heading of 354 because if i
didn't apply these corrections and i
flew a heading of 360 based on my
compass i would actually be flying a
true heading of 006 in this case so the
moral of the story is if you want to fly
a specific true heading you have to
calculate a magnetic heading in order to
do that and to come up with that
magnetic heading you subtract easterly
variation and add westerly variation a
good memory aid is east is least and
west is best okay but how do i know how
much variation is where i'm at most
aeronautical charts are labeled with
specific lines designated with how much
variation is in that location these are
called isogonic lines
now this line where the variation is
zero this is called an aegonic line
on this particular chart these red
isogonic lines show you where the east
variation is and the blue ones show you
where the west variation is but on a vfr
sectional these lines are all shown in
magenta with a little e or a little w
depicting whether it's easterly or
westerly variation but as you can tell
you basically have to have a chart in
order to know what the variation is in
your area but if you were to straighten
out these isogonic lines of variation
what you would get is a globe about this
shape and that's the real reason for
variation i'm just kidding i don't
actually believe all that
all right so let's take a look at one of
these isogonic lines on a vfr sectional
as you can see this one right here is
four degrees west
so if i want to fly a true heading of
zero nine zero i'd have to add that four
degrees to get a magnetic heading of
zero nine four all right so let's pull
out the vfr navigation log and see how
we're going to use this in flight when
you do your cross country planning
before we apply the variation we should
have already corrected our true course
for the winds this is called the wind
correction angle and once we do this we
get our true heading typically you'll
use a flight computer to come up with
the wing correction angle i'll show you
how to do that in a future episode
so we already said that our true heading
was 090
now let's add in our variation and if
you forget the little jingle take a look
up here they give you the answer
and we had four degrees of westerly
variation so let's add four degrees to
that to get our magnetic heading of zero
nine four now you're probably noticing
that we're still missing one piece of
the puzzle and that's deviation in your
airplane anything that uses electricity
and even certain types of metals can put
off a magnetic field these also cause
errors in our compass and this is what
we call deviation but there's actually a
way to correct for this
every time an airplane comes new from
the factory or it has a new piece of
equipment installed the people who do
the maintenance are supposed to take the
airplane to the compass rows and check
the difference between what the magnetic
compass is supposed to read and what it
actually reads
then they write the difference on these
little compass deviation cards and stick
it to the compass you've probably seen
these on your compass and wonder what
the heck these are and the way these
usually work is they tell you which
course heading to fly if you want to fly
an accurate magnetic heading so in this
case if i want to fly a 360 magnetic
heading i would actually have to steer
to a zero zero two course heading now on
rare occasion you may see these
corrections written in easterly and
westerly form in that case you would
subtract and add just like you do the
variation just remember east is least
and west is best
now to take that deviation and throw it
over on the nav log let's grab the
closest heading we can find here in this
case it's 0 9 0 because we're flying at
0 nine four remember so now if i want to
be accurate it looks like i need to add
one degree to my heading and that gives
me a final course heading of zero nine
five and that's all you have to do to
correct for deviation hey if you learned
anything from this video today would you
smash that like button for me but don't
stop now with your studying check out
this video right here it might just be
the reason why you pass your check ride
see
ya position
you